returned to orlando last sunday and dr
rivers was not happy he had a quarantine
for seven days
given it was an excused absence but he
got out today
and all the coaches have talked about
being so vocal on the bench
doncic floats it up and in chitchat went
back to the locker room with a hurt
ankle
and now they're up by one
doncic nails the three-pointer
luke dodges now 11 points and three
assists getting help
eight points for porzingis and dallas
with the lead after
they signed it back in february after
charlotte waved him his first seven and
a half years with charlotte
doncic again gets inside trying to draw
some contact
he thought he got hit as well airspace
to get the three
dutches season opening drives inside the
wages kind of holds on to the ball takes
some contact and banks at home
true all the time blame and the receiver
instead of saying
that was a poorly thrown pass doncic
puts it in
over zubats who was right on top of him
that he got tossed yep
doncic for three as the shot clock
expires
hardaway goes back up top dodge's
side step lays it up and then beautiful
euro step from doncic
gwad open but seth curry in the corner
all by himself
so they have options reggie jackson
comes in to help he either can lay it up
or toss it to a knockdown shooter
quad lennon inserted into the game the
last two possessions is like
take a break i got you gotcha has it
going again
now has 34. that time paul george made
the play
that's a great look for beverly dacha
spins inside
flips it up and in
[Applause]
doncic fakes leans in bank shot is good
38 points for doncic
well just as mark said no shot blocking
at the rim gives them an opportunity to
switch pretty much everything
doncic drives on jackson gets inside
lays it in easily
got a good skill set and a terrific
competitive spirit about it
maverick's still alive doncic drives
gets inside lays it up and in it's a
four-point game